m ce qui oblige les partenaires comme tu
dis qu'à se remettre autour de la table
presque ne pourrait pas y avoir de
dérive populiste vrai que leurs proches
de risque doit d'avoir des votations sur
des sujets dits populiste est réelle
mais je pense malgré tout que le
meilleur moyen pour lutter contre le
populisme c'est précisément d'en
discuter et de trancher
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soirée du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 15 septembre
et quel bilan en afghanistan un mois
jour pour jour après la prise de la
capitale afghane par les talibans le
retrait américain sur les droits de
l'homme la presse ou encore la culture
les fondamentalismes multiplient les
déclarations rassurantes mais qu'en
est-il de la réalité sur le terrain
serait dirige-t-on vraiment vers une
normalisation diplomatique
décryptage dans quelques instants
on ne peut pas se permettre une
surenchère des promesses de dépenses ou
de baisses d'impôts pierre moscovici le
premier président de la cour des comptes
met en garde à sept mois de la
présidentielle alors que les candidats
déclarés ou non promettent des chèques à
tout va le premier à avoir ouvert le bal
c'est évidemment le président mais kron
mais la france peut être se permettre de
telles dépenses qui va finalement payé
l'addition dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire on en parlera en deuxième
partie d'émission
et puis à 21h notre rendez-vous qu'en
pensent les français nous sommes à dès
ce soir à la rencontre d'un pompier
réfractaires à la vaccination alors que
depuis ce matin sa profession fait
partie de celles qui doivent présenter
un schéma vaccinal complet ou la preuve
d'une première dose pour exercer pour
protester stéphane sabatier c'est son
nom ont entamé une grève de la faim
après son témoignage place au débat avec
nos invités
et avant de retrouver nos invités sur ce
plateau régis le sommier reza jafari
pour un décryptage petit détour par
l'afghanistan un mois dont jour pour
jour après la prise de kaboul par les
talibans et fondamentalistes islamistes
de retour au pouvoir tente désormais de
maintenir la bénisse temps dont le
concert des nations de leur côté l'onu
et l'europe des blocs est défaut pour le
pays guyomard aussi
l'afghanistan sur la voie d'une
normalisation diplomatique
c'est en tous les cas la volonté
affichée par le pouvoir taliban de
nouveau aux manettes depuis un mois le
ministre des affaires étrangères du
nouveau gouvernement a exprimé ce mardi
sa reconnaissance envers la communauté
internationale
à cette conférence un milliard de
dollars dead a été promis pour
l'afghanistan nous remercions tous les
pays et organisations qui ont promis
cette aide
c'est une bonne action et nous la
saluons
en plus de saluer cet engagement nous
promettons que l'émirat islamique
coopérera totalement pour fournir cette
aide aux personnes dans le besoin
une aide bienvenue est nécessaire dans
un pays dévasté par plus de 40 années de
guerre et qui doit désormais affronter
une sécheresse sévère en plus des
conséquences de la pandémie de kobe 19
certains comme ici dans les rues de
kaboul sont contraints de vendre leur
bien pour fuir ou simplement se nourrir
une situation humanitaire qui rend
essentiel le maintien d'un contact avec
les talibans c'est alors oui nous devons
avoir un dialogue je veux insister là
dessus parce que le pouvoir qui est en
afghanistan n'est pas stable notre
modèle est stable les talibans ne sont
pas une réalité politique ou nietzsche
il ya aussi des frictions et des
conflits entre eux et du ch telle est
mangeable et nous devons rapidement
ouvrir un canal de discussion pour
pouvoir distribuer l'aide et essayer
d'évacuer les personnes vulnérables que
nous devons protéger leur
protection
distribution de l'aide justement est
reparti timidement ces derniers jours
avec la reprise des vols du programme
alimentaire mondial à destination de
kaboul et la distribution de denrées aux
plus démunis et les vols humanitaires ne
sont pas les seuls à avoir repris un
appareil commercial s'est posé sur le
tarmac de l'aéroport de la capitale
afghane ce lundi en provenance du
pakistan le premier depuis la conquête
des talibans ces nouveaux maîtres du
pays dont tous espèrent également qu'ils
tiendront leurs promesses faites aux
femmes afghanes notamment leur droit de
travailler et d'étudier l'un des sujets
qui préoccupent le plus les observateurs
internationaux et qui pourrait bien
servir de thermostats s'agissant des
relations diplomatiques entre kaboul et
ses interlocuteurs occidentaux et un
mois après la prise de kaboul donc par
les taliban quel avenir pour
l'afghanistan peut-on s'attendre à une
normalisation des relations entre les
fondamentalistes et le reste du monde
enfin comment l'aide financière va t
elle être utilisée c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir reza
jafari président de l'association
enfants d'afghanistan bonsoir eisa
jafari merci d'être avec nous régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france merci
régis être là donc à moi un jour pour
jour après la prise de kaboul reza
jafari quelle est la situation sur place
ce que vous avez des remontées
d'afghanistan
à kaboul comme on sait qu'il ya encore
la présence de
quelques journalistes on a des images
les talibans ont sorti les fous et on
est retourné dans les années
quatre-vingt seize mais par contre dans
les zones reculées et dans les autres
provinces comme dans le valais de
peinture dans la province du panjchir où
il y à une guerre les talibans les
tribunaux talibans ont commencé à donner
les ordres d'exécution mais aussi dans
les autres provinces comme des provinces
daykundi qui a majoritairement habité
par les hasards a qui sont minoritaires
en afghanistan et
ce matin plusieurs centaines d des
habitants de province de kandahar ont
manifesté parce que les talibans les
oblige à se déplacer et à partir dans
les autres provinces parce que
apparemment ils ont un projet de faire
venir d'autres mondes d'ailleurs et les
installer à kandahar mais ce monde vient
d'où pour l'instant c'est on pense qu'
il veut le faire venir à des pachtouns
qui sont de l'autre côté de d1 tribales
c'est à dire le pakistan et les faire
revenir à kandahar non c'est pas très
optimiste régis le sommier ce que nous
dit reza jafarzadeh on s'en relève
volonté de reprise à la vie normale par
les talibans évidemment qu'ils veulent
être on l'a dit souvent un interlocuteur
pour notamment les occidentaux ils ont
fait une opération clairement de
séduction de l'occident en même temps il
ya deux messages chez les talibans
clairement la composition du
gouvernement qu'ils ont donnée est en
opposition qui est à destination de
leurs troupes qui rassemble d'ailleurs
les différentes tendances en entendu le
une deux secrétaires de l'union
européenne déclaré qu'ils avaient des
tensions au sein des talibans et que la
situation n'était pas stable au niveau
gouvernemental elle ne l'est pas en
effet on sait qu'il ya une opposition
depuis longtemps entre le réseau haqqani
enfin la famille le clan haqqani qui
tient une partie de l'appareil militaire
taliban et le mollah baradar qui le
négociateur qui était le négociateur en
chef à doha et que l'un et l'autre une
représentation dans le gouvernement donc
en fait le gouvernement a été un message
à destination des troupes talibane à
destination de ceux qui avaient gagné
des vainqueurs et pas tellement à
destination de l'international où les
américains et la communauté avait pressé
pour qu'il y ait là l'inclusion d'un
certain nombre de personnes de la
société civile et éventuellement de
l'opposition il n'y a rien eu tout ça
jusqu'à présent et en même temps on a vu
les taliban continuer à tolérer
effectivement que les journalistes
fassent leur métier même s'il est
encadrée même s'il ya des contraintes
continue à documenter ce qui se passe et
notamment à kaboul et on les a vus aussi
on a vu les déclarations
remerciant la communauté internationale
appelant aussi on l'a vu aussi à des
nouvelles relations avec les états unis
a souhaité ce qui est des bonnes
relations qui se tissent sur les
talibans sont pas naïfs ils savent que
aujourd'hui à une crise humanitaire une
crise alimentaire en afghanistan qui va
petite touche à peu près un tiers de la
population afghane c'est énorme et qu'
ils ne pourront pas continuer à se bâtir
au pouvoir s'il ya une énorme famille en
afghanistan parce que les afghans d'une
certaine façon une partie de la
population fait confiance aux talibans
après vingt ans de guerre 40 20 ans
d'occupation américaines 40 ans de
guerre beaucoup d'afghans sont
complètement là c est se disent
finalement si les talibans arrivent
apporter la paix ben pourquoi pas
l'aimer et la télé qui les finance est
un minimum pour survivre et c'est en
cela que la population les a à l'oeil
d'une certaine façon l'afghanistan est
un pays ingouvernable
c'est un pays qui a toujours été
traversé par des envahisseurs qui n'ont
jamais pu s'y maintenir et les taliban
compris donc ils savent très bien qu'il
peut y avoir aussi des révoltes qui peut
y avoir des zones qui leur échappe et
asseoir leur pouvoir sur l'ensemble du
pays est une condition et cette
condition passe par le maintien d'une
activité économique de flux financiers
et la gestion d'un pays ce qu'ils n'ont
pas fait depuis 20 ans puisqu'ils n'ont
pas été au pouvoir depuis un an dans
tout ce temps-là rapidement justement
reza jafari et rendre avant de parler de
la destination de ces z1 quelle est la
situation en ce moment on nous parle ans
parce qu'on sait que le retrait
américain a été l'occasion de l'arrêt un
des aides de la communauté
internationale la situation est critique
notamment pour les plus faibles les
enfants par exemple
la plupart des gens sont en train de
vendre leur affaire leur bien même leur
maison
il y en a beaucoup qui essayent de
partir et quitter le pays parce qu'ils
veulent pas vivre assouline des talibans
rappeler que ça fait 20 ans la nouvelle
génération a connu qu la république vécu
sous une république aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que la famine touche la population
afghane et que
sûrement il va ya il y a déjà des
oppositions des fronts de résistances
dans le pays et mais avec les dernières
nouvelles qu'on a partout en afghanistan
le peuple est en train de se lever
contre ce régime en tout cas l'union
européenne elle redoute vraiment une
crise humanitaire dans le pays et elle
annonce vouloir renforcer son aide à
destination
l'afghanistan la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen s'exprimer sur ce sujet
nous devons continuer à soutenir tous
les afghans dont le pays et dans les
pays voisins nous devons tout faire pour
éviter le risque réel d'une famine
majeure et d'une catastrophe humanitaire
et nous ferons notre part nous
augmenterons à nouveau l'aide
humanitaire à l'afghanistan de 100
millions d'euros cela fera partie d'un
nouveau paquet de soutien à gand plus
large que nous présenterons dans les
prochaines semaines pour unir tous nos
efforts
de nextrx
régis donc l'union européenne 1 qui met
la main à la poche en de nouveaux l'onu
qui s est engagé à verser un peu plus
d'un milliard d'euros dead on donne
lettre sans contrepartie pour le moment
est ce que on est certain que c'est une
bonne stratégie puisque on le donne
forcément au gouvernement taliban qui va
le gérer pour la population c'est
toujours problème de déco monde des
aides humanitaires c'est à dire de
savoir qu'elle fait la réalité de la
houle entendu un des porte parole
taliban a assuré la communauté
internationale que cette aide serait
bien acheminé contexte est très
particulier
bien sûr le contexte est particulier et
bien sûr qu'on a aucune certitude que
cette aide va bien par exemple vous
parlez des hasards à tout à l'heure il
ya un certain nombre de populations
comme ça qui sont directement la cible
des talibans depuis très longtemps mais
même sous l'occupation américaine il ya
un certain nombre de gens qui sont voilà
visé est ce que ces gens s'ils sont en
besoin avant de recevoir cette aide rien
n'est moins sûr est ce que les talibans
vont la partage est déjà rentré parle
pour les populations
dont ils ont le support ça
fera sûrement pouvoir il va falloir pour
qui une réalité tangible et puis surtout
ce qu'ils aimeraient faire la communauté
internationale on le sent bien mais il
n'y a pas vraiment de de menaces ni de
des changes c'est d'assurer par exemple
que le droit des femmes le droit des
femmes un travail et le droit des femmes
à étudier soit garantie par les taliban
les talibans ont assuré mais est ce que
dans une deuxième phase ils vont pas
dire finalement dans un char ya la femme
doit être au foyer puisque c'est souvent
sur ces textes là en disant nous
appliquerons la charia qui peuvent se
permettre d'adopter un double discours
là pour le moment ils ont officiellement
autorisé les femmes à se rendre à
l'université on l'a vu avec des
contraintes particulières dont il
dévoile et puis surtout au sahel sont
autorisés à partir cinq minutes avant
les hommes pour pas se mélanger que ça
c'est une obsession des talibans c'est
que les hommes et les femmes ne se
croisent jamais ça fait partie de ce
qu'on remarque quand on va passer du
temps avec eux c'est qu'il ya une espèce
de voile à une cloison en absolu dans la
société civile entre hommes et femmes et
est donc l université ils ont commencé à
appliquer ça ou n'ont donc pas interdit
aux femmes de retourner à l'université
ce qui n'était pas le cas dans la
précédente administration talibane là il
n'y avait pas de besoin de faire des
appels du pied à la communauté
internationale d'aider facto
l'afghanistan était devenu un internet à
part ya les talibans n'ont pas
réellement cherché à avoir de l'aide je
dirais comme comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il joue une
partition qui est leur survie ils savent
très bien qu'il ya des points de
fragilité on afghanistan comme je le
répète c'est un pays extrêmement
difficile à contrôler toutes les zones
de l'est sont des zones qui est la
plupart du temps et échappé au pouvoir
central comme par hasard c'est que la
dèche s'était implanté je parle de l'est
et du nord les provinces de kunar de
nangarhar qui sont extrêmement
difficiles à contrôler tout ce qui est
autour de la frontière et les talibans
savent bien que pour asseoir leur
pouvoir il va leur falloir des finances
il va leur falloir une économie va leur
falloir une administration et ils ont
tout intérêt à coopérer avec la
communauté internationale après à la
communauté internationale effectivement
de données en fonction peut-être de
monnaie d'échangé de pouvoir faire
pression sur ce gouvernement taliban est
justement le secrétaire général des
nations unies goûter reste exhorté un
épi justement à mettre la main à la
poche écouter
le peuple afghan a besoin d'une bouée de
sauvetage après des décennies de guerres
de souffrance et d'insécurité il est
peut être confronté à son oeuvre la plus
périlleuse
aïeul jeetoo se porte en flèche et pile
je vous demande instamment de soutenir
notre appel éclair de 606 millions de
dollars afin d'apporter une aide urgente
à 11 millions de personnes au cours des
quatre prochains mois nous annonçons
aujourd'hui une allocation de 20
millions de dollars du fonds central
d'intervention d'urgence des nations
unies pour soutenir l'opération
humanitaire en afghanistan dumas les
terrils operation in afghanistan
résa jafari et antonio guterres est qui
veut se servir de cet argent il le
disait comme levier pour tous les autres
aspects qui préoccupent la communauté
internationale citant le terrorisme la
drogue les droits humains il ya une
forme de naïveté pour vous chez le
secrétaire
nationale de pardon le secrétaire
national secrétaire général je vais y
arriver des nations unies est-ce que
vous en tant qu'humanitaires vous êtes à
peu près confiant sur la destination de
cet argent non non pas du tout
beaucoup ont tiré de leçon à part les
occidentaux et
d'abord les américains qui font un
accord avec les talibans avec une vente
des terroristes qu'on les appelait
encore il y a quelques mois et
maintenant ça devient un gouvernement
légitime en négociant avec eux on leur
donne plus de légitimité et aujourd'hui
on parle d'un raz de créer un rapport de
force avec les talibans elle est un jour
de depuis le début et ce qu'ils ont tenu
un de leurs engagements mais jamais ils
parlaient d'un gouvernement inclusif
aujourd'hui on a un gouvernement d qui
est composé des
talibans des terroristes recherchés par
le monde entier pour vous il fallait
verser cette aide il faut verser cette
aide justement pour la population il n'y
a pas le choix ou au contraire ça peut
être un moyen de pression ça peut être
un moyen de négociation avec les
talibans surtout depuis les débuts où on
crie qu'il faut maintenant négocier avec
les talibans pour ouvrir les couloirs
humanitaires pour les gens qui veulent
sortir puisse le faire et en même temps
soutenir le zéro indjai et ne pas donner
tous aux talibans pour qu'ils soient un
petit peu dépendante des ong qui sont il
y a encore quelques uns des courageuses
qui sont restés en afghanistan qu'ils
sont sur place et qu'on les connaît ils
font un frère un travail extraordinaire
sur place mais aujourd'hui il
travaillait avec le gouvernement taliban
là
les américains je pense que c'est en
train de regretter déjà avec les accords
de doigts et que la communauté
internationale va être de toute façon
obligé à coopérer à travailler avec les
talibans mais ce travail va être de plus
en plus c'est difficile et compliqué
puisqu'il il n'y a pas de queue présence
de la communauté internationale en
afghanistan on ne peut pas surveiller et
que les talibans à aucun moment on peut
faire confiance à une bande je rappelle
encore une fois une bande de terroristes
et justement à propos des américains
dernière question un peu plus politique
régissant selon les journées du
washington post en plusieurs ministres
américain et membres de l'otan ont tenté
de convaincre joe biden de pousser le
retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan de repousser et évidemment
ça fait polémique jova et donne aurait
refusé par crainte d'être embourbé dans
le pays ça vous semble crédible cette
information tout est possible ou en tout
cas ce qu'on sait c'est que quand tony
blinken jeux d'antan dès hier soir
déclaré devant le congrès que le
renseignement américains n'avaient pas
prévu un écroulement aussi rapide bien
durant ce
mois j'étais en afghanistan juillet et
je peux vous dire que deux choses
d'abord à l'époque des embuscades y en
avait à 10 km de kaboul les talibans
étaient vraiment à l'extérieur ce que tu
on est allé rencontrer à l'époque que
pour faire un documentaire dans leur
zone contrôlé la plupart des provinces à
quelques kilomètres du centre ville et
étaient capables d'ailleurs de tendre
des embuscades jusque dans les zones
gouvernementales donc on sentait
vraiment cette fragilité on sentait
aussi que kaboul à l'est et à l'ouest en
tout cas moi j'ai pu le contestent le
compte vous constatez n'était pas
défendu il y avait
mes danemark était une ville charnière
où là il y avait un peu de présence de
l'armée la green zone là où étaient les
américains ou et toutes les ambassades
et toutes les administrations
elles étaient défendues si vous voulez
mais la ville en tant que telle n'était
pas défendu jalalabad idem on a su après
que jalal abad pendant deux mois
avait été l'objet de négociations entre
les talibans et qu'il n'y a pas eu un
coup de feu lors de la reddition de la
ville ça c'est le premier aspect
deuxième aspect si moi je me souviens
des discussions que j'ai eues avec
d'amis david martinon l'ambassadeur de
france c'était au début juillet qui me
disait que le 17 juillet la france a
comme en avait affrêté un vol pour
rapatrier c'est que ses ressortissants
quatre vols avaient déjà eu lieu depuis
mai pour rapatrier aussi l'être les
traducteurs et un certain nombre
d'interprètes et des gens qui
souhaitaient quitter l'afghanistan sur
le constat que il y allait avoir un
écroulement rapide donc la question je
me pose c'est quel est ce que les
français avaient des informations que
les américains n'avaient pas parce que
les français on replié en bon ordre et
ont affrété je vous dis dès juillet donc
c'est on est un mois avant la chute de
kaboul un avion pour dire à ceux qui
sont dans le pays c'est votre dernière
chance partait donc là la question c'est
quand blinken nous dit nous n'avions pas
d'informations
le renseignement américain nous donner
ses propres tout tout simplement faux et
je ne comprends pas pourquoi les
américains n'ont pas anticipé et ça
c'est vraiment de la faute de john
hayden on peut pas accuser
l'administration précédente donald trump
je ne sais qui d'avoir provoqué ce que
cette catastrophe résa jafari le mot de
la fin les afghans que vous avez
j'imagine sur place peut-être parfois
par vous échangez peut-être avec eux ya
un sentiment de trahison justement quand
on voit ce retrait américain un peu
catastrophique
quel est le sentiment de la population
sur place depuis vingt ans des promesses
déprendre de promesses en l'air des
promesses qui n'ont pas été tenues et
qu'au final l'afghanistan étaient vendus
quel sens a été rendu
talibans et comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure c'était un accord avec les
talibans c'étaient les accords de doha
est aujourd'hui les afghans surtout la
nouvelle génération se sont vraiment
très non seulement par les américains
mais aussi par son propre gouvernement
par la communauté internationale
aujourd'hui tout le monde abandonne
l'afghanistan et la génération est ce
qu'on demande aujourd'hui
c'est de ne pas abandonner son peuple et
soutenir surtout cette nouvelle
génération qui est attachée aux valeurs
qu'on partage
tous ici parce que la nouvelle
génération comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est une génération qui a grandi sous
une république c'est une démocratie
il y avait une certaine liberté
d'expression on perd tout ça et surtout
les femmes ceux qui ont bâti pendant
toute ces dernières années elle peur de
tout du jour au lendemain ils vont
résister malgré le danger de mort et je
suis sûr que l on réussira pas seulement
aujourd'hui presque il y à 37 millions
afghans en afghanistan les talibans
quand ils sont arrivés c'était vers 60
mille aujourd'hui si le l'afghanistan
est tombé assez rapidement parce qu'il y
avait des dirigeants corrompus on n'a
fait que trop confiance aux chefs de
guerre déjà en 96 si les talibans ont
réussi à prendre le l'organiste ans
c'était parce que il en avait marre des
moudjahidine et des chefs de guerre
aujourd'hui on a fait les mêmes erreurs
de faire confiance au chef de guerre qui
ont dès que les talibans sont arrivés
ont quitté l'afghanistan merci beaucoup
en tout cas de témoignages reza jafari
régissent le saunier on vous garde avec
nous si vous le voulez bien puisqu'on va
aborder un autre thème de l'actualité
internationale avec notamment la
question de la présence du groupe
militaire russe wagner homélie aucun
militaire russe n'est déployé sur place
au mali c'est ce qu'affirme aujourd'hui
mitri peskov le porte parole du kremlin
qui répond ainsi à des accusations
bamako et du chef de la diplomatie
française jean yves le drian selon
moscou il n'y a pas de négociations en
cours entre les autorités maliennes et
le groupe paramilitaire russe wagner
notre correspondante à moscou vera
d'hoffmann
aucun militaire russe n'est présent au
mali a affirmé le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov la présidence
russe réagissait ainsi à la déclaration
du chef de la diplomatie française jean
yves le drian qui a qualifié d'
incompatible une éventuelle implication
de la société militaire privée wagner
dans le pays avec le maintien des forces
françaises jouent propose d'écouter
comics nous n'avons aucune information à
ce sujet
et pour revenir à votre question
il n'y a là bas aucun représentant des
forces armées russes
et aucune négociation officielle est en
cours puis partons de ce fait
ce n'est pas la première fois que le
chef de la diplomatie française 100 kg n
du rôle accru de la russie en afrique
jean yves le drian avait dénoncé je cite
une présence active de la russie récente
significative antilles françaises dans
la république centrafricaine jean yves
le drian avait ensuite confirmé que ce
n'était pas vraiment l'armée russe qui
étaient positionnées en centrafrique
mais la force wagner la russie a
toujours affirmé que son aide en
centrafrique se faisait conformément au
droit et aux objectifs de la communauté
internationale écoutez nous pouvons
répéter qu'en réponse à la demande des
dirigeants centrafricain et au su du
comité des sanctions du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu 21 27 pour la
république centrafricaine
175 instructeur russe chargé de former
le personnel militaire centrafricain ont
été envoyés dans ce pays en 2018 par la
suite le nombre des instructeurs est
passé à 235 étant donné le fait que la
situation s'est fortement aggravée à la
veille des élections législatives de
décembre 2020 la russie à la demande des
autorités centrafricaines à envoyer 300
instructeurs de plus dans ce pays pour
former le personnel de l'armée nationale
chargée d'assurer la sécurité avant et
pendant le scrutin récemment un autre
groupe de six ans instructeur est
arrivée à bangui 200 pour larmes et de
sang pour la police et 200 pour la
gendarmerie nationale une notification
en ce sens a également été envoyée au
comité des sanctions du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu 21 27 d'après moscou
aucun instructeur russe n'est
directement impliqués dans les
hostilités contre les groupes armés
illégaux dans la république
centrafricaine
et ses accusations sur la présence de
militaires russes au mali lancé à la
fois par la france et bamako c
l'objet de notre décryptage avec régis
le sommier qui est resté avec nous et
xavier moreau directeur strates paul
bonsoir xavier moreau merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui donc moss conquis qui
prend la parole et dément formellement
la présence de ses troupes une une
réponse des démos roaa la france qui
verrait cette initiative d'un très
mauvais oeil
si vous voulez le les mercenaires ça
sert à ça sert à pouvoir intervenir dans
des zones particulières sans engager un
état et surtout sans engager sa
diplomatie donc aujourd'hui moi je n'ai
pas d'information particulière
permettrait de confirmer ou d'achat mais
qu'il y a des des mercenaires russes sur
place mais je dirais que c'est de bonne
guerre c'est le deuxième plus vieux
métier du monde et ça a été largement
utilisé par la russie notamment en syrie
où quand vous voulez envoyer des gens
faire des guerres on vous ne voulez pas
être impliqué directement ou que vous ne
voulez pas que les mères de famille des
conscrits russes ou même des
professionnels russes et bien pleure la
mort de leurs de leurs soldats dans ce
cas vous envoyer des mercenaires c'est
ce que les russes ont fait en
centrafrique c'est là la france le fait
les états unis le fonds est généralement
ça apparaît après des conflits où il y
avait énormément de volontaires et
c'était le cas notamment du conflit en
ukraine vous avez énormément de groupes
qui sont allés volontaire dans le bonne
basse et qui ont pris goût et bien à
cette manière de vivre et notamment de
gagner et de gagner sa vie et c'est pas
un hasard si d'ailleurs wagner est
réellement apparu après les événements
en ukraine alors le ministre malien de
la défense eut admis à mener ses
pourparlers avec cette société militaire
privée rêver se souvient quel est
l'intérêt du du pouvoir malien de
changer finalement d'interlocuteurs dans
sa lutte contre les groupes jihadistes
alors c'est pas complètement changer
d'interlocuteur en tout cas après faire
évoluer les choses quand on sait que les
relations sont difficiles entre emmanuel
macron et assimilés aux états qui est le
double putschistes puisqu'il a donc
renouvelé son coup d'état l'année
dernière on sait qu' il ya eu plus il ya
eu des tensions emmanuel macron décidé
de mettre fin à l'opération barkan pour
progressivement la transformer entre une
opération impliquant les forces
spéciales européennes sous la forme de
ce qu'on appelle la task force takouba
et que voilà le deal qui est en train
d'être fait enfin la lettre le point
d'achoppement le point de discussion
entre les français et les maliens
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si les
maliens vont s'entendre ou en tout cas
vont essayer de faire revenir dans
l'équation nationale d un certain nombre
de groupes djihadistes de deux groupes
ce qu'on appelle les gâte là bas les
groupes armés terroristes avec lesquels
il ya des discussions tout simplement le
colonel goût et a été lui même capturé
par un de ces groupes et il a été libéré
par un imam célèbre là bas qui s'appelle
l'imam dicko qui lui négocié beaucoup
avec ces groupes et donc il me tentait
cette tentation une tentative justement
de la part du gouvernement de d'essayer
de 2,2 voilà mais jusqu'où va certes
cette tentative et c'est là où la
présence française là bas est mise en
cause c'est à dire que les françaises là
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils font de la
chasse à ces groupes armés terroristes
ils essayent de rétablir une forme de
légitimité du pouvoir dans le pays et en
même temps le gouvernement malien lui
négocié avec ces groupes dont il ya un
il ya un conflit qui ce prêt qui se
entre les deux et est le problème qui
est posé aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
la finalité de l'intervention française
qu'une intervention qui date depuis 2013
je le rappelle d'abord c'est
l'intervalle et ensuite en 2014 marc
khanne aujourd'hui la l'école là la
force est en train de muter elle est
mais elle est toujours très investi 1
moi j étais j'étais sur ta coupe
barrages et et j'ai participé des
opérations avec eux cet âge force en
avril dernier je peux vous dire que dans
la zone de ménaka qui est à l'est du
pays qui était une zone une petite
commune petite garnison il ya deux ans
aujourd'hui une base gigantesque est en
train de se construire avec une présence
des tchèques une présence des suédois
une présence des commandes et estoniens
toutes les beaucoup de pays sont sont là
pour effectivement
continuer cette traque aux terroristes
dans le sahel le problème c'est qu'à en
parallèle il ya eu peu de résultats dans
la reconstitution d'un service public
dans certaines zones
et que les terroristes finalement sont
comme des poissons dans l'eau donc c'est
un conflit qui semble être un conflit
sans fin avec ce qui s'est passé en
afghanistan est revenue
les que la question à nouveau été posée
c'est de se dire
la france est elle est aussi engagée
dans un conflit sans fin la france
est-elle doit-elle rester indéfiniment
au sahel au risque de voir le pays
s'écroule et c'est ce qu'on avait dit à
propos des états unis pour l'afghanistan
c'est ce qu'on la dit également pour
l'irak donc le la question elle est là
aujourd'hui maintenant d'autres
partenaires d'autres comme aux acteurs
existent dans l'âme dans les environs
les maliens joue sur plusieurs tableaux
ça c'est évident maintenant la réalité
tangible de l'accord avec le groupe
wagner on n'en sait rien on n'en sait
rien on a quand même le précédent qui
avait été cité tout à l'heure de la
centrafrique où le groupe wagner a formé
la garde nationale du président a formé
une partie de l'armée donc a déjà pris
souche dans un pays qui était autrefois
un territoire français enfin un
territoire de sous influence française
et xavier moreau en tout cas la france
elle ne veut pas en entendre parler un
jean yves le drian était bien clair il a
prévenu que l'indication de ce groupe
serait absolument incompatible avec le
maintien de la force française ça
pourrait peut-être dans le contexte que
vient de nous expliqué régis le sommier
s'avérer fort utile la france est en
mauvaise posture et est quasi sûr la fin
au mali
moi je suis d'accord avec ce que vient
diriger ce sommet c'est à dire que pour
les dirigeants maliens c'est un bon
moyen de faire pression sur la france
puisqu'il ya le précédent centrafricain
et c'est pas parce que wagner est
impliqué que l'armée russe va
immédiatement débarquer donc là-dessus
faut être il faut être modéré je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les russes n'ont pas
l'ambition de remplacer dans une zone
qui est kama s'éloigner de leurs centres
d'intérêt de remplacer l'armée française
où la coalition européenne en question
vraiment je sais que ça c'est vrai que
les les affres et les dirigeants
africains sont pas sont pas plus idiot
que les autres et ils ont bien compris
que il était désormais courtisé pour
différentes raisons politico
stratégiques comme leur foi par exemple
au sein de l'assemblée
des nations unies il était concilie
était courtisé par la chine par la
russie la russie a tenu son sommeil
russe afrique en avant 2019 toutes les
grandes puissances africaines étaient
présentes et pour le les autorités
maliennes actuelle c'est un très bon
moyen de faire pression sur la france
pour les obliger d'une part peut-être à
s'investir davantage et surtout pour ne
pas vouloir s'immiscer dans les affaires
intérieures de ce qu'ils estiment être
des affaires intérieures des autorités
maliennes parce que ça aussi c'est une
spécificité de la diplomatie russe et
qu'elle ne fait pas de leçons de morale
aux dans les pays dans lequel dans
lequel elle s'investit allait prendre
toujours du recul contient un coup
d'état les attentes de voir ce que ça
donne et pourrait en gros et essayer
d'être en s'immisçant moins possible du
côté du vainqueur et ce qui n'est pas le
cas de la france qui est toujours des
prétentions avoir instauré la démocratie
telle qu'elle l'entend partout dans le
monde notamment en afrique qui est une
des dernières zones sur lesquelles on
écoute encore un petit peu donc c'est
très à mon avis c'est très habile de la
part des autorités maliennes de jouer la
carte de wagner qui pour l'instant ne
donne pas de ça doit pas entraîner un
bouleversement de rapports de force sur
terrain merci en tout cas tous les deux
pour votre analyse et les desaulniers
xavier moreau merci d'avoir été avec
nous
il y à un peu plus d'un an le liban
vivent et l'effroi suite à l'explosion
du port de beyrouth depuis ce drame
l'enquète local piétiner les familles
des victimes n'arrive toujours pas à
faire le deuil pour tenter d'accélérer
les investigations 145 organisations de
défense des droits humains survivants et
proches de victimes ont appelé
aujourd'hui l'onu à ouvrir une enquête
internationale indépendante et précision
de nicolas petit
la pression s'accentue chaque jour un
peu plus sur les autorités libanaises
pour enfin établir les responsabilités
et les sanctions liées à l'explosion du
4-août 2020 qui a fait 214 morts et plus
de 6500 blessés human rights watch
amnesty international et plus de 140
organisations ont adressé ce mercredi
une lettre ouverte au conseil des droits
de l'homme de l'onu avec un message on
ne peut plus clair l'incapacité de l'
enquête nationale à garantir
l'obligation de rendre des comptes
illustre de manière spectaculaire la
culture plus large d'impunité des
fonctionnaires qui prévaut depuis
longtemps en liban
l'obstruction éhontée des autorités à la
quête de vérité et de justice des
victimes renforce la nécessité d'une
enquête internationale sur l'incapacité
de l'état libanais à protéger le droit à
la vie bien que les autorités est
immédiatement reconnu que l'explosion du
port de beyrouth était dû au stockage
sans mesure de précaution d'énormes
quantités de nitrate d'ammonium
elles ont aussi rejeté d'emblée la
perspective d'une enquête internationale
mais les investigations menées au niveau
local n'avance pas et les politiques au
pouvoir fuient leurs responsabilités
alors que le premier juge en charge de
l'enquêté a été dessaisi de ses
fonctions après l'inculpation de hauts
responsables son remplaçant a dû faire
face au refus du parlement de lever
l'immunité de certains députés une
situation qui exaspère les proches et
familles de victimes qui ont à plusieurs
reprises manifesté leur mécontentement
ces dernières semaines comme ici devant
la résidence de l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur par intérim mohamed fahmi
deux jours avant l'anniversaire de
l'explosion du port de beyrouth leur
porte parole a mis en garde publiquement
les autorités
aux autorités qu'ils nous demandent de
maintenir le calme dans la rue nous ne
sommes pas vos employés et ce n'est pas
notre rôle de servir comme votre police
discipline et c'est le droit de chaque
libanais d'exprimer sa colère et son
mécontentement à votre égard à travers
tous les moyens légitimes et disponible
après que vous ayez détruit le pays
alors que personne n'essaie de faire une
médiation concernant cela une enquête
indépendante impartiale rapide et
transparente c'est en substance ce que
réclament les proches et familles de
victimes érigée par emmanuel macron
comme la condition sinequanone pour
débloquer l'aide internationale et
tenter de sortir le pays de l'impasse la
nomination d'un nouveau gouvernement
vendredi dernier après plus d'un an des
chèques à y parvenir n'est pas pour
autant signe d'espoir une bonne partie
de la population reste toujours
sceptique vis-à-vis du pouvoir exécutif
accusé de rester entre les mains d'une
classe politique corrompue
et la situation au liban on en parle
tout de suite avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanche maison on vient
donc de l'entendre à la population qui
ne sont pas soulagées même que la
nomination récente d'un nouveau
gouvernement une équipe qui va
rapidement devoir prouver qu'elle est
vous à la hauteur cette fois si oui
alors la classe politique libanaise
comme on dit a mis 13 mois pour
accoucher de ce gouvernement est
assurément des contraintes l'accord de
taef veut que le premier ministre soit
sunnite c'est le cas mais en fait il ya
eu d'autres essais auparavant le pré
vert la république étant chrétien
maronite et le président de l'assemblée
de l'assemblée étant lui-même s'y met
évidemment monsieur boukatif a été
choisi comme premier ministre n'est pas
un perdreau de l'année en réalité il ya
déjà été premier ministre deux fois donc
dans une période de crise juste après
l'assassinât de rafic hariri c'est un
homme d'affaires à succès qui est
peillard d'air et qui a déjà été aussi
ministre des télécommunications au liban
alors il réunit les conditions dans le
fond parce que il connaît à la fois les
codes du milieu politique libanais et
les codes du fmi de la banque mondiale
de l'union européenne pour obtenir les
financements les financements qui pour
le moment sont gelés dans le liban a
cruellement besoin il a formé une équipe
de 24 min ce qui est aussi correspondent
aux équilibre très délicat entre les
trois tendances religieuses plus les
druzes et c'est très délicat parce que
chacun veut avoir des ministères très
particulier en fonction de l'accès qu'il
donne au pouvoir à l'influencé aussi à
l'argent par conséquent c'est pour ça
que ça a pris aussi longtemps pour
former ce gouvernement qui est
probablement est aujourd'hui ce que la
classe politique libanaise compte tenu
de ce qu'elle est peut produire de mieux
avec un aspect technocratique pour un
certain nombre de ministres même s'ils
sont rattachés chacun à une de ses
filières religieuse alors ses membres de
cette équipe sont tout de même il faut
bien le dire accusé d'être étroitement
associé à la classe politique corrompue
pourtant ce gouvernement inné de la
pression internationale notamment
française celle d' emmanuel macron lui
même ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément été entendu ces français
je pense qu'encore une fois compte tenu
des contraintes de la politique
libanaise c'est ce qui pouvait être fait
de mieux sans révolution à rien voilà
sans révolution dans l'état actuel des
choses et je pense que cette équipe va
en effet avoir à faire ses preuves alors
le premier tech silva arrivé cette
semaine le billet des finances a annoncé
qu'il déclenchait un audit de la banque
centrale libanaise et cet audit est
exigée par le fmi depuis longtemps pour
reprendre ses financements jusqu'à
présent il ya eu des tentatives diverses
pour avoir cet audit est à chaque fois
le gouverneur de la banque centrale a
refusé l'accès de ses bureaux et de ses
comptes au contrôleur donc on va voir ce
qui va se passer à la fin de la semaine
lorsque wall la semaine prochaine
lorsque l'eau dite commencera mais c'est
un
un test très important et puis
naturellement ce gouvernement va devoir
s'attaquer à des réformes de structures
qui sont indispensables pour obtenir des
financement ultérieur de l'union
européenne de la banque mondiale du fmi
et là il n'est pas certain que cet
équilibre très fragile entre les
diverses factions permettent de faire
les réformes de structure qui devrait
s'imposer alors effectivement la
population et sceptiques et pensent que
ce gouvernement est issu de cette classe
politique assez largement corrompu et
n'aura pas là l'énergie politique pour
faire les réformes qui serait nécessaire
or la situation est catastrophique à
tous les égards hyper inflation chômage
massif les jeunes veulent partir bien
sûr les libanais qui ont de l'argent
sont partis depuis longtemps et le pays
est en train de sombrer et de sombrer
également dans la dans la faillite et on
parle évidemment de l'explosion du port
de beyrouth qui a été un véritable
séisme sont le fonds humanitaire
également les proches des victimes
attendent toujours des réponses il y à
même la demande d'une ouverture d'une
enquête internationale indépendante
clairement que peut on attendre de la
communauté internationale sur ce point
alors en effet il y avait un premier
juge libanais qui a été nommé il a été
déchargé du dossier et qu'il a voulu
inculpé déjà important un deuxième l'a
remplacé et il est en train de lui
arriver la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sortent à l'inertie de la classe
politique en troisième lieu le parlement
refuse de lever l'immunité de l'immunité
parlementaire des députés de toutes tel
ou tel député et par conséquent l
enquête nationale cin vers complètement
enlisé alors que le président à eaunes
ne veut pas d'enquêté internationale il
considère que ça serait tout à fait
contraire à l'indépendance du liban ce
serait une ingérence intolérable alors
ya évidemment un précédent un peu dans
des conditions peut-être encore plus
dramatique lors de l'assassinât
rick hariri le secrétaire général de
l'époque kofi annan a déclenché une
enquête internationale mais il savait
qu'il avait l'appui du conseil de
sécurité et qu'il n'y avait pas de veto
daoud aucun membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité il a présenté ce rapport au
conseil de sécurité et le conseil de
sécurité a créé un tribunal
international pour juger les ce qu'ils
avaient à satiné tard et carrie est
effectivement la situation n'est pas la
même les circonstances internationales
ne sont pas là même les mêmes non plus
je pense qu'aujourd'hui même s'il
s'agissait de l'assassinât d'un premier
ministre il n'y aurait pas d'unanimité
au conseil des ministres au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu pour créer une
instance internationale par conséquent
les ong ont 145 ong ont donc sollicité
le conseil des droits de l'homme de
genève qui n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
qui peut évidemment en discuter mais qui
pourra pas prendre de mesures actives
pour qui ne pourra pas agir sur une
enquête internationale alors il reste la
dernière solution c'est en effet de
faire pression en disant en négociant
avec ce gouvernement libanais la
présence d'experts d'autres pays à
l'intérieur de l'équipe d' enquête
savait déjà été proposé par monsieur
macron d'ailleurs qui avait proposé les
experts spécialistes de ces sujets pour
débloquer l'anc est pour le moment c'est
pas possible à suivre donc merci que
gans maison merci d'avoir été avec nous
et autres pays où l'incertitude
politique reste de mise la tunisie ou la
non d'un nouvel exécutif se fait
toujours attendre la nomination dans les
plus brefs délais d'un gouvernement une
possible réforme de la constitution
soumise à référendum des mesures
évoquées hier soir au palais de carthage
entre le président kaïs saïd et quelques
juristes conviés dans la perspective
d'une sortie de crise des précisions de
notre correspondant à tunis baisse chez
be
notre pays est gouverné par une mafia
démo de kane sayed sont claires fort et
résonne comme une mise en garde pour
tout ce qu'ils considèrent comme
responsables de la crise politique dans
laquelle le pays est plongé depuis des
années ces propos le chef de l'état les
a tenus devant des juristes invités au
palais de carthage une étape importante
à ses yeux on concernant le programme
qu'il prépare pour l'avenir de la
tunisie écoutez
c'est un état de régime un régime
apparent celui des institutions et un
régime réel celui de la mafia qui
gouverne la tunisie gr.d
tarpon plus tôt voilà plus d'un mois et
demi que le chef de l'état s'est arrogé
les pleins pouvoirs en limogeant le
premier ministre et en gelant les
travaux parlementaires des mesures
exceptionnelles qui n'a pas hésité à
renouveler les 24 août dernier elle ce
pour une durée indéterminée et depuis
classes politiques société civile et
communauté internationale demeure dans
l'attende une feuille de route claire et
d'un retour à la normale pour les
affaires institutionnelles et politiques
alors que beaucoup de tunisiens ont
accueilli avec enthousiasme ce coup de
force celui de la promesse d'un
changement radical nombreux sont les
politiques avocats aux membres de la
société civile qui craignent une dérive
autoritaire du pouvoir c'est le cas du
parti ennahdha première formation
politique de pays avant le 25 juillet
qui a exprimé son rejet de toute
suspension de l'application de la
constitution ou d'un éventuel changement
du système politique faisant fi de toute
critique et fort d'un soutien populaire
l homme aux commandes du pays a annoncé
la nomination d'un chef du gouvernement
dans les jours à venir
alors faut qu'il s'inquiétait de l'état
des finances publiques en france le
premier président de la cour des comptes
tire en tout cas la sonnette d'alarmé
rappel à l'ordre à l'occasion de la
présentation aujourd'hui de son rapport
devant les députés sur l'évolution des
dépenses publiques pendant la crise
sanitaire pour pierre moscovici on ne
peut pas se lancer dans une surenchère
de promesses de dépenses ou de baisses
d'impôts fin de citation le premier
président de la cour des comptes qui met
donc les points sur les i à sept mois de
la présidentielle et à une semaine de la
présentation du dernier budget du
quinquennat et justement alors qui va
payer alors que la france doit se
relever de la crise économique les
candidats sont-ils lancés dans une
surenchère pour conquérir le coeur des
français on en parle tout de suite avec
notre reporter katia pique nique devant
bercy bonsoir katia alors les promesses
de chèques qui viennent d'abord du
président lui même on l'a remarqué ces
derniers jours katia
et oui en effet c'est fini alors je suis
plutôt devant la cour des comptes en
effet emmanuel macron se montre
extrêmement généreux en lui le le
chantre de il n'y a pas d'argent magique
il se met à distribuer les millions et
les milliards en tout cas reparlons de
ce rapport de la cour des comptes ce que
vous citiez donc rapport des dépenses
pendant la crise il est vrai que la
croissance repart au beau fixe et que
l'emploi a atteint son taux d'avant
l'épidémie mais le budget du quoi qu'il
en coûte à l'essai des impacts
préoccupant dans les finances publiques
avec un fort niveau d'endettement et le
rapport relève surtout que 14 % des
dépenses ne sont pas liées à la crise
épidémique soit 13,7 milliards sur les
96 points 4 milliards d'augmentation
total certes un peu se sont pas
réversible comme par exemple les
dépenses liées ou ségur de la santé et
emmanuel macron donc le voilà même s'il
a annoncé la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
continue à distribuer comme par exemple
50 millions d'euros pour la filière de
la pêche qui est entravée par la fin du
bre exit donc pour la soutenir bien il
ya cette petite manne qui leur est
donnée comme annoncé hier également 1,5
milliard d'euros supplémentaires pour la
sécurité
et puis le gouvernement va également
doter le programme territoire
d'industrie de 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires dont vous voyez que nous
sommes en plein feu de dépenses on le
voit bien donc tout et sociaux sont en
train de changer un par rapport à des
politiques d'austérité revendiqué au
début du mandat et pierre moscovici le
président le premier président de la
cour des comptes suggère de mieux
maîtriser les dépenses et exhorte
emmanuel macron à se montrer vigilants
et katia emmanuel macron qui sort donc à
le chéquier à sept mois de la
présidentielle mais ce n'est pas le seul
à formuler de tels engagements
financiers aussi important
et oui je pense irait une envolée des
chéquiers un peu généralisés les
candidats se montrent généreux de
manière générale mais sans faire le
distinguo entre une dépense
d'investissement qui est qu un effet de
levier qui est compensée et une dépenses
pérennes qui revient chaque année ne
parle pas non plus des recettes alors
commençons par parler d' anne hidalgo
qui veut doubler le salaire des
enseignants ce avec une facture de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
à la clé marine le pen et arnaud de
montebourg arnaud montebourg pardon
veulent nationaliser les autoroutes
c'est le même tarif quant à valérie
pécresse elle souhaite le doublement de
la défiscalisation des emplois à
domicile et surtout abracadabra
l'augmentation de 10% des salaires nets
des français en baissant les charges
salariales jean luc mélenchon quant à
lui souhaite créer un milliard d'emplois
publics donc les candidats ont tendance
à se montrer excessivement généreux bien
plus qu'en 2017 or le premier président
de la cour des comptes exhorte surtout à
ne pas multiplier les promesses de
dépenses comme vous le disiez ou de
baisses d'impôts et surtout surtout à
créer une de programmation dès le début
du prochain quinquennat pour inverser la
courbe de l'endettement
merci katia technique notre reporter ont
des règles depuis la cour des comptes
alors est ce raisonnable de promettre
des millions d'euros pour cette période
de crise sanitaire les candidats
déclarés ou non pourront vraiment tenir
leurs promesses qui va finalement payé
on en parle tout de suite avec notre
invité l'économiste christian
saint-etienne
bonsoir christian saint-etienne merci
d'être avec nous on ne peut pas se
lancer dans aucun dans une surenchère de
promesses de dépenses ou de baisses
d'impôts tout d'abord qu'est-ce que vous
inspire cette petite phrase de pierre
moscovici il a raison
il a raison sur le fond il a été aussi
le ministre d'un gouvernement qui avait
au début ce hollande lâcher la dépense
mais effectivement la situation est
totalement différente
aujourd'hui nous avons un endettement
public qui dépasse 100 points de pipe
nous avons un déficit public qui est au
plus haut niveau dans la zone euro et
nous avons une économie qui reprend un
peu de dynamisme mais ça ne règle aucun
des problèmes structurels en fait c'est
le point central bis que si on se cale
sur les prévisions de croissance de la
banque de france si on prend les quatre
années parce que tout le monde évoque le
rebond d'activité de 6% cette année mais
c'est après -8 l'année dernière la
banque de france annonce 3,7 en 2022 et
un peu moins de deux ans en 2023 si on
prend ces quatre années ça fait
seulement 4 % de croissance
au total c'est à dire 1 % par an or la
france a besoin de doubler ce taux de
croissance c'est d'ailleurs le même taux
de croissance que celui que nous avons
depuis une quinzaine d'années qui tourne
autour de 1,3 1,4 donc la crise a fait
quand on est un peu en dessous de ceux
1,3 1,4 alors que la france pour se
moderniser pour se réindustrialiser pour
régler le problème du déficit extérieur
aurait besoin d'un investissement
productif
considérables et aur ait besoin
réindustrialiser le pays donc à man
annoncé des hausses de dépenses
publiques qui
vont alourdir la barque risque de
décourager les investisseurs privés donc
c'est extrêmement inquiétant c'est
d'autant plus inquiétant que comme je le
disais il ya quelques secondes les
problèmes structurels français ne sont
pas réglés nous avons toujours le record
de dépenses publiques dans la zone euro
nous avons un niveau de dépenses
publiques
si on corrige de la crise qui reste
autour de 56 57 points pipe c'est de
l'ordre de 9 points de pipe de plus que
les pays comparables c'est à dire de 100
milliards
quand on a 200 milliards de dépenses
publiques de plus que les autres c'est
des impôts en plus ou du déficit qui il
finit
sera comblé par des impôts futurs voilà
donc il ya un autre problème qui est
encore plus central c'est que la dépense
publique française n'est pas efficace si
nous avions 56 points dépenses publiques
mais un taux de chômage de 3% une
croissance à 3 4% par an un taux de
chômage des jeunes quasi inexistant on
dirait c'est un modèle économique qui
fonctionne mais nous avons 56 57 points
de dépenses publiques avec un niveau de
chômage très élevé avec une insécurité
qui est considérable avec une
désindustrialisation massive avec un
déficit extérieur donc on voit que dans
normalement le quinquennat qui se
termine aurait dû être le quinquennat
des réformes structurelles qui
permettait de corriger la situation
française ça n'a pas été le cas à cause
de la crise du coc vide le prochain
quinquennat doit impérativement être le
sait la dernière chance de faire les
réformes structurelles avant des chocs
et une violence inouïe qui pourrait
intervenir avec la remontée des taux
d'intérêt et parce que si les taux
remontent quand vous avez une dette qui
est à 110 points 115 points de pib il
est évident que ça coûte très cher donc
les les annonces que votre journaliste
devant la cour des comptes a rappelé
totalement délirante par exemple
d'hidalgo de doubler les salaires des
enseignants sans préciser que par
exemple dans les pays où les salaires
sont plus élevés les enseignants
notamment en allemagne ou ailleurs
accepte par exemple d'enseigner deux
matières alors qu'en france un
enseignant de refuse d'enseignés plus de
2 many matière les syndicats s'y
opposent totalement les dans les autres
pays où les enseignants sont mieux payés
les ces enseignants acceptent également
de travailler davantage donc voilà on
parle de doubler les salaires sans
modification structurelle dans tous les
domaines c'est ce qui se passe on a fait
le ségur de la santé mais il n'y a pas
eu de réforme structurelle de l'hôpital
alors christian saint-pierre il n'y a
pas que quand ils madame hidalgo qui
effectivement candidate à l'élection
présidentielle qui fait des promesses il
ya le président actuel qui qui distribue
ans qui sort son carnet de chèques en ce
moment on l'a vu à marseille
certainement qu'on en a effectivement
besoin ça c'est pas le sujet de
l'interview marseillais hier la police
est ce qu'aujourd'hui clairement
on a on rentre assez d'argent pour en
ressortir autant vous venez nous
expliquer que non mais le président
pourtant fait tout l'un vertes n'est ce
pas alors c'est un président en campagne
qui a sorti le carnet de chèques pour
essayer d'attirer les électeurs
effectivement que l'on investisse à
marseille que l'on investisse
massivement dans la recherche le
développement les infrastructures les
universités là le la réindustrialisation
du pays est une bonne chose mais dans ce
cas là il faut couper dans la dépense de
fonctionnement qui est inefficace ont
évoqué précédemment donc il faut une
réforme des retraites il faut une
réforme du système hospitalier
il faut une réforme de l'école puisque
les la réussite des élèves français et
très insatisfaisante nous sommes tombés
très bas dans les classements pisode de
l' ocde donc
faire des dépenses dans des domaines où
c'est souhaitable c'est une bonne chose
sous réserve de réduire ailleurs pour
enclencher comme le dit le président
moscovici de la cour des comptes une
programmation annuelle qui nous ramène
assez rapidement vers un niveau de
déficit qui idéalement doit être
inférieur à 2% du pib' pour contrôler
l'évolution la dette publique or
actuellement on est plutôt au triple de
ses 2 % donc on est actuellement dans un
délire de dépenses qu'il tient pas
compte de la réalité de la situation
économique française
merci en tout cas tu les as tu y as
saint-etienne pour cet éclairage merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur rt france
rester avec nous dans quelques instants
ce soir dans notre rue qu'en pensent les
français donc ça nous allait à la
rencontre d'un pompier réfractaires à la
vaccination alors que depuis ce matin sa
profession fait partie de celles qui
doivent présenter un schéma vaccinal
complet ou la preuve d'une première dose
pour exercer
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
cette dernière année a été plutôt
heureuse pour les bouches les bourses
mondiales alors que la crise sanitaire
on n'est pas tout à fait terminée
comment est ce que vous vous expliquer
cette hausse vous avez le les banques
centrales qui déversent des liquidités
massivement et les flèches vers la
bourse aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus
aucune corrélation entre l'activité
réelle le pib est le les marchés
financiers le jour où les banques
centrales ont décidé de tout arrêter
tous les marchés
reviendront à la réalité on risque
d'avoir justement un éclatement de la
bulle est aujourd'hui l'action des
banques centrales est bien plus pervers
que ça parce qu'elle détruit l'économie
grecque de nos jours il n'ya aucun
trader qui n'ose aller contrer le marché
parce que là cette force gesink et la
force de des banques centrales est trop
forte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse d'industrie
elle est extrêmement contre les
coupables puisque on reverse 50 5 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires à l'état et à
la commune ils sont donc très intéressé
au fait que le fonctionnement soit clean
on fait exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurances est ce qu il ya
de l'argent suspect nous sommes dans
l'obligation de le déclarer comment se
répartit 100 euros de mise globalement
aux machines à sou par exemple moi j'ai
dans l'obligation de vendre en moyenne
85% nous on n'a absolument aucun intérêt
à ce que quelqu'un aille raconter qu'il
est ruiné au casino pas certains vous
pouvez dépenser des sommes extrêmement
importantes allant jusqu'au million
d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe et on
est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nombre
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission notre
rendez-vous qu'en france les français
nous sommes allés ce soir à la rencontre
d'un pompier réfractaires à la
vaccination alors que depuis ce matin sa
profession fait partie de celles qui
doivent présenter un schéma vaccinal
complet ou la preuve d'une première dose
pour exercer pour protester stéphane
sabatier entamé une grève de la faim
après son témoignage
place au débat avec nos invités
[Musique]
soignants pompiers ou encore
ambulanciers et doivent donc présenté
depuis ce matin schéma vaccinal complet
ou la preuve qu'ils ont reçu une
première dose en france on en parle dans
quelques minutes mais avant cela on
prend la direction des états unis joe
biden a justement rendu la vaccination
obligatoire pour 100 millions de
travailleurs fonctionnaires du
gouvernement fédéral et salariés du
privé on retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas
est ce que le gouvernement américain
avancent aussi vers une vaccination
obligatoire pour tous
oui on peut dire que plusieurs étapes
ont déjà été franchie en ce sens on est
loin désormais de la politique
d'incitation qui était en vigueur il ya
encore quelques mois au début de cette
campagne vaccinale alors ce qui a changé
depuis évidemment c'est l'émergence du
variant delta et une couverture
vaccinale aux états unis jugées
insuffisantes par les autorités
sanitaires alors au départ la liberté a
été donnée aux différentes entités que
ce soit des entreprises ou des
établissements scolaires voire des états
d'imposer ou non la vaccination mais
depuis quelques semaines le gouvernement
a donc repris la main en imposant
d'abord aux employés fédéraux de se
faire vacciner puis donc la semaine
dernière de nouvelles annonces de la
part de joe biden qui veut aller encore
plus loin on écoute
il ne s'agit pas de liberté ou de choix
personnel il s'agit de vous protéger et
de protéger ceux qui vous entourent les
personnes avec qui vous travaillez les
personnes auxquels vous tenez les
personnes que vous aimez mon travail en
tant que président et de protéger tous
les américains donc ce soir j'annonce
que le ministère du travail élabore une
règle d'urgence pour exiger de tous les
employeurs consent employés ou plus qui
emploient ensemble plus de 80 millions
de travailleurs de s'assurer que leurs
effectifs sont entièrement vaccinés ou
présente un test négatif au moins une
fois par semaine
alors cette mesure concerne environ 100
millions de salariés américains il faut
noter que les soignants sont aussi est
concernée par ces mesures d' obligation
de vaccination puis maintenant c'est au
tour des soldats des forces armées
américaines de se faire vacciner ils ont
une date limite qui a été fixée au 15
décembre prochain pour procéder à cette
injection alors ces décisions de son
four ne se font pas sans une certaine
résistance des personnes concernées
comme en france il ya une forte
opposition à cette vaccination
obligatoire aux etats-unis cette
opposition elle s'articule notamment
autour de la notion de liberté qui vous
le savez est une valeur chère aux yeux
des amériques et thomas comme souvent
aux états unis l'opposition s'opère sur
le terrain judiciaire avec une plainte
déposée hier par les autorités de
l'arizona
oui le gouverneur républicain de
l'arizona qui s'oppose donc à cette
obligation de vaccination voici ses
propos le gouvernement byden bafoue une
nouvelle fois nos lois et notre
jurisprudence pour promouvoir ses idées
radicales voilà donc pour les
déclarations du procureur général de
l'état mark snow beach alors il ya une
gouverne une comparaison qui a été
effectué par les autorités en arizona
entre le sort des américains qui doivent
donc faire face pour certains à une
obligation de vaccination et les
immigrés illégaux qui arrivent sur le
territoire et qui est évidemment non pas
de preuves de vaccination a montré à
lodja aussi une affaire dans l'état de
new york puisque un juge de l'état de
new york a bloqué l'obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants qui devait entrer en
vigueur le 27 septembre prochain au
motif que cette obligation faisait fi à
des motifs religieux qui peuvent être
invoqués par les américains pour
justement ne pas procéder à cette
vaccination et c'est une particularité
ici le motif religieux peut donc être
invoqué pour échapper à cette obligation
de vaccination c'est ce qui est arrivé
notamment dans les rangs de la police de
los angeles la prochaine étape ici aux
etats-unis ça pourrait être les
passagers des vols qui devraient pouvoir
qui devrait bientôt de présenter une
preuve de vaccination c'est en train
d'être discutées au sein de la maison
blanche mais il ya une interrogation
comment vérifier le statut vaccinal des
américains alors que le gouvernement a
promis qu'ils ne mettraient en place ni
passeport vaccinale ni qr codes comme
c'est le cas en france merci thomas
bonnet pour ca précision en direct de
washington et en france donc un
l'obligation vaccinale est entré en
vigueur aujourd'hui pour plusieurs corps
de métier on le disait c'est le cas pour
les sapeurs pompiers professionnels
ambulanciers ou encore soignants ceux
qui ne sont pas en règle ne peuvent donc
plus exercer leur profession
certains soignants refuse toujours de se
faire vacciner malgré le risque de voir
leur contrat suspendu et donc leurs
salaires alors que l'exécutif affiche sa
fermeté des syndicats redoutent des
ruptures de soins faute de personnel
suffisant on voit cela en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
et cette piqûre obligatoire c'est un
véritable chamboulement pour bon nombre
de professions mais qu'en pensent les
français nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de stéphane sabatier sapeurs
pompiers volontaires pour protester
contre l'obligation vaccinale ce père de
famille a même entamé une grève de la
faim sur le toit de sa caserne avant que
le gign interviennent pour le faire
descendre un reportage signé luca léger
avant de retrouver nos invités
nous sommes à oysonville en eure-et-loir
je me trouve avec monsieur s'abattit
pompiers qui ne veut pas de la
vaccination bonjour monsieur sabatier
merci de nous recevoir chez vous tout
simplement vous pouvez m'expliquer
depuis combien de temps vous êtes
pompiers et pourquoi ça a été la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase bah
moi je suis pompier depuis l'âge de 16
ans j'ai des pompiers ici
je suis rentré à 20 ans quand un pompier
de paris je suis retraité des pompiers
de paris et depuis dix ans j'étais je
suis pompier volontaire à la caserne
nabli dans le 78 juste à côté à partir
du 15 septembre comme je veux pas faire
vacciner ben je serai plus pompier mon
métier et mon expérience il ya une à
deux injections pourquoi vous avez
autant de packs d'eau devant chez vous
j'ai décidé de faire un jeune de
contester une grève de la faim alors une
grève de la faim sur le toit de la
caserne j'ai pas dormi de la nuit dont
je suis resté là haut pour fall est
monté sur le toit toutes les pancartes
les tout matériel les tentes et tout
j'étais très bien installés j'aurais pu
rester très longtemps alors
malheureusement j'ai prévenu en très
honnêtement j'ai contacté ma direction
qui elle est obligée en fait ma
direction est obligé de suivre la loi
c'est clair et je leur en veux pas
mais mon erreur c'est que je les ai
prévenus et pas parler dans les médias
ça sera peut-être passées différemment
je sais pas ce que vous avez à faire aux
gendarmes oui le gg n'est venu pour
négocier mois pour mme irma footeux
redescendre
moi je suis pas un bon dit non plus j'ai
des enfants
visa et mes enfants finir en garde à vue
c'était moyen donc là ils m'ont expliqué
que comme j'ai été
pacifistes et ben du coup bah là
gérard huot qu'une aucune charge contre
moi en fait mon erreur c'est que les
médias n'étaient pas sur place parce
qu'ils ont bouclé tout là toutes les
accès vers la caserne pour pas qu'il y
ait des images en fait tu vois
ça c'était ma première médaille pour
acte de courage et dévouement celle-ci
jeté pour un feu voilà un feu de infl
hôpital fernand widal et celle-ci en
fait c'est le feu la rue de provence le
feu plus meurtrier après la libération
de paris est-ce que c'est dur
d'envisager de quitter cette profession
que vous avez exercé pendant des
décennies avant 30 ans fait forcément ça
fait une deuxième c'est une deuxième
famille le
des pompiers
compass 72 heures d'affilée avec des
collègues ça il ya des affinités c'est
ma deuxième famille moi ma famille je la
quittais je retrouve une deuxième là bas
en tant que pompier c'est comme ça alors
dans ma tête c'est très clair je serai
jamais plus de pompiers voilà j'ai fait
le deuil c'est triste mais c'est comme
ça et financièrement vous allez vous en
sortir comment alors moi concrètement
jeu comme j'étais pompier volontaire
j'avais ma retraite de pompiers de paris
891 euros pour 10 80 pompiers de paris
est en fête avec madjo avait décidé avec
ma femme d'être comme une femme
travaille des pères au foyer en fait
donc depuis dix ans je suis père au
foyer je m'occupe des nos enfants dans
les sorties scolaires show côte coach
dans deux balles de deux équipes et
je faisais 1000 euros voilà je leur
avais à gagner 1000 euros on était en
prenait en moyenne 1000 euros et mille
euros c'est bah c'est simplement la
somme qui qui sort tous les mois pour
les études de métro gare c'est tout donc
on avait sorti retrouver un certain
équilibre donc je suis pas feignant jeu
retrouvé un travail ça s'est su en mai
milieu rouge les retrouve et voilà il ya
pas de problème mais voilà c'est ça tous
voient toute notre vie à s'écrouler rien
en fait
vous m'avez dit que le fait qu'on incite
vos enfants à se faire vacciner ça avait
été un déclic dans votre dans votre
motivation est ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer un peu en détail ce qui
s'est passé mes trois enfants sont
passés en sélection handball c'est à
dire qu'ils sont ils font partie des
meilleurs joueurs du département lui est
toujours en sélection de balle et
en sélection départementale pardon et à
lui en plus de ça il était sélectionné
pour rentrer au centre d'entraînement
départemental dont qui quittait son son
collège de deux secteurs pour partir à
chartres en tant que à l'internât donc à
13 ans à partir d'un internat pour
pouvoir asseoir fc devenir en valeur il
a donc du coup à deux jours de la
rentrée on nous a appelés en nous disant
à partir du 30 septembre votre fils na
faux faux faux savoir si les vaccinés ou
si il à savoir si l'impasse sanitaires
et comme on peut le faire vacciner on
nous a dit bah faut qu'ils quittent la
section donc là on a pris la décision de
le remettre dans son collège alors le
gamin
voilà c'est on a pris la décision avec
lui le peu dit il il veut pas se
résigner il n'y a pas envie pour une
population qui pourra toucher donc c'est
vraiment une décision politique qui a
vraiment bouleversé votre vie assez
vraiment où il annonce de monsieur le
président a bouleversé nos dit
totalement totalement que ce soit pour
notre maison mon métier ou pour mes
gamins pour pour toute la famille pour
là on a tous arrêtés plus ou moins longs
ont pour l'instant autant qu'on peut
faire des tests on joue les deux jours
on pourra plus faire les tests on pourra
plus jouer dans l'offre politique qu'on
est déjà en train de vie n'est pour la
présidentielle qui arrive est ce que
vous trouvez que sur le pass sanitaire
il ya un vrai débat moi ce que je veux
c'est qu'il y ait un candidat qui bat
qu'ils
nous fassent au bas pour moi pour mes
gamins c'est qu'ils fassent sauter le
pas sanitaires simplement c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça
emmanuel macron l'avait dit cet été nous
devront sans doute nous poser la
question de la vaccination obligatoire
pour tous depuis aujourd'hui soignants
pompiers ambulanciers aides à domicile
et certains gendarmes sont donc
concernées par l'obligation vaccinale au
delà de la suspension du contrat de
travail que risquent les professionnels
réfractaires c'est l'objet de notre face
à face ce soir
[Musique]
remparts les nous sommes avec georges
kuzmanovic présidents de républiques
souveraines bonsoir georges merci d'être
avec nous jean marc flipo porte-parole
de debout la france bonsoir à vous aussi
tout d'abord georges kuzmanovic qu'on
vous voyez ce pompier qui d'une certaine
manière risque sa carrière risque toutes
les ambitions de son fils qui rêve
d'être footballeur professionnel qui
évidemment change de collège qui ne le
sera jamais parce qu'il ne veut pas se
faire vacciner ça vous évoque quoi
vous savez je suis je trouve ça terrible
pour ce monsieur comme pour tant
d'autres qui vont se retrouver dans de
grandes difficultés d'autant plus que
nous sommes dans un contexte de crise
sociale économique qui suit la crise de
l'aco vide et j'en veux considérablement
emmanuel macron on a d'autres pays comme
nos voisins
très latin qu'ils sont que sont
espagnols qui sont très très largement
vacciner bien plus qu'en france sans
qu'il y ait autant de problèmes mais ils
ont eu un gouvernement qui a été qui n'a
pas menti qui a été honnête qui a dit
que quand ça n'allait pas ça n'allait
pas quand ils ne savaient pas ils ne
savaient pas nous on a eu un
gouvernement qui a tout fait qui a pensé
qu'on pouvait arrêter qui a dit qu'il
n'y en a pas de cas de crise qu'il n'y
aurait pas de contamination massive qui
a dit après que des flyers dans les
aéroports arrêterait les contaminations
qui a dit que les masques servent à rien
puisque les masques étaient dangereux et
puis que les masques étaient
obligatoires y laissa coûté 135 euros de
ne pas en avoir et puis qu'on pouvait on
ne pouvait sortir qu'elle pouvait plus
sortir et puis on pouvait au pouvoir à
nouveau sortir mais en signant soi même
sa propre autorisation ce qui évidemment
fait rire à peu près toute la planète
on a un président qui ne croyaient pas
au vaccin là où par exemple donald trump
a financé 40 6 milliards et qui fait que
nous avons les vaccins modern haifa isr
après c'est en décembre dernier par un
coup qui le disons c'est grâce à donald
38 mais il faudra payer
et un suivi entre la politique et il ya
les affaires médiatiques
les choses sont ne sont pas si
différentes que ça en particulier dans
ce domaine
on a un président qui en décembre
dernier disait qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'il ya dans le vaccin qui a nourrit
donc est la confusion chez les chez nos
concitoyens et puis qui tout à coup un
pause se passe
sanitaires
et en même temps
en faisant passer la réforme des
retraites tout à fait néolibérales
imposées par l'union européenne
s'attaquant à l'assurance chômage mais
ça s'est passé
oui il ya des choses qui passent dans
les cavaliers part dans le parlementaire
donc ils font bien leur travail pour
saper nos retraites
et est donc une obligation vaccinale de
facto mais dont sont exempts les forces
de l'ordre qui sont amenés à contrôler
si les gens ont bien fait lors la
vaccination à toute personne normale se
dit on est dans un pays de fous en tout
cas ce qui me dirige sont complètement
insensé et c'est bien c'est bien normal
puisque la campagne
vaccinale être organisée par des
consultants donc notre gouverneur
président emmanuel macron a préféré ne
pas se baser sur les services compétents
d'état ou sur nos militaires qui savent
gérer des questions de crise mais sur un
mac kinsey inquiétudes qui tout à coup
c'est trouver très compétente dans la
domaine de la vaccination de masse ce
qui est tout à fait intéressant jean
marc flipo vous quand vous voyez
effectivement ce ce pompier c'est vrai
que quand on interroge dans ses
motivations d'ailleurs il a du mal à les
exprimer mais ça ne regarde finalement
ça vous inspire quoi vous vous dites il
s'acharne au contraire non il défend
tout simplement sa liberté ce monsieur
il est droit dans ses bottes ça
m'inspire de jeu une immense tristesse
de voir que se payant en soit arrivé là
je vais pas revenir sur son inventaire
que fait monsieur qu'aux novices qui
effectivement il y avait un journaliste
allemand une journaliste allemande qui
avait qualifié tous adeptes sur distants
il faudra juste savoir si c'est
uniquement de l'absurdité ou s'il ya un
moment donné il ya eu des desseins
cachés on commence à voir des ministres
défilent et la cour de justice de la
république pense qu'on en a une je pense
que c'est à ces appelés à monter à
monter un petit peu plus haut sur
l'obligation le traitement qu'on inflige
aux soignants le traitement qu'on
inflige aux pompiers que star c'est un
pur scandale et là aussi ça pose ça
posait pas de question au mois de
février mars avril 2020 on les a envoyés
en première ligne sans rien on se
rappelle tous de ces images de soignants
en train de s'équiper avec des sacs
poubelles pour faire leur travail en ad
certains qui étaient contaminés qui se
savaient contaminées dont on a exigé
qu'ils aillent soigner leur malade
pourquoi parce que on l'a on a dit à
l'époque oui mais ces gens la
connaissent les gestes barrières ils
savent se protéger protéger leurs
masques et en plus de ça n'avait pas de
matériel il faut il faisait comme il
pouvait mais à l'époque on disait il
sape 6 à protéger leurs patients alors
aujourd'hui on les accuse littéralement
d'être des criminels c'est insupportable
vous avez à peu près 300 milles
soignants en france qui sont dans ce cas
là alors qu'on manque de personnel alors
qu'au manque de lits mais il faut être
complètement fou pardon
même 90% des soignants qui sont vaccinés
oui mais ça fait trois cent mille
personnes qui ne sont pas attention
c'est que sur le chu de nice nous un
article dans nice-matin aujourd'hui sur
le ch ministre représente des centaines
de personnes sur un seul chu mais je
passe vous réalisez ce que ça va
commencer le système de santé français
va être impactée comment le système
hospitalier qui est déjà au bord de
l'explosion va être impactée les
ambulanciers avec 13% dambulla
ambulanciers qui ne sont pas vaccinés on
commence à reporter les prises en charge
de malades est là pour l'instant on
parle que du vide mais quid des malades
des couples de des cancers quid des
personnes qui doivent aller se faire
dépister pour d'autres maladies enfin on
est en train de on est en train de
répéter
les erreurs qu'on a commises au début de
l'épidémie comme si rien ne s'était
passé et moi je pose la question parce
qu'on commence à entendre la petite
musique qui revient du cinquième au fond
noir et combien 5/5 vague je crois
maintenant
imaginons qu'on a un autre variante qui
arrive parce qu'on a laissé l'afrique
totalement non vaccinés ce cas un autre
scandale absolument inimaginable
imaginons qu'on allait avoir les
pays pauvres sur 4 milliards qui ont été
distribués dans les pays riches et vous
avez l'om est ce qui vient encore une
fois de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé avec
son directeur général le dr gabriel sous
ce mardi dernier en disant qu' il aurait
à peu près un quart des doses qu'ils
n'utilisent avait besoin pour par des
prochains si vous laissez le terrain de
jeu au virus en afrique on peut très
bien dans un variant plus virulents plus
contaminant qui va revenir qu'est ce
qu'on va faire à ce moment là s'il veut
que si le vaccin n'est pas efficace où
sont les stocks de masques ffp2 où sont
les purificateurs où sont les lits
d'hôpitaux voilà on part dans un autre
débat mais clairement vous qu'on se
mette en cause mais david pardon
candidat à l'élection présidentielle on
le rappelle vous rendriez la vaccination
obligatoire aujourd'hui on entend cette
musique aussi aux états unis emmanuel
macron le 12 juillet dernier j'y vois là
ça va devenir un débat à la rentrée
clairement
vous franchirez ce pas là aujourd'hui
dans la vraie les collectifs si j'avais
été président j'aurais pas fait toutes
les inepties café ce gouvernement avant
et donc
l'autorité de la parole présidentielle
aurait été prise beaucoup plus au
sérieux c'est là qu'est le problème
c'est ce gouvernement qui est la cause
de ce chaos
mais moi j'aurais été pour l'obligation
vaccinale mais en la faisant comment de
la faire c'est à dire en ayant nous
mêmes nos vaccins on ne les sent pas par
exemple le vaccin de fabriquer en france
de manière plus classique à
saint-herblain être achetés par les par
les britanniques nous aurions aussi
également investi pour
avoir d'autres vaccins et puis surtout
on aurait organisé de manière qui soit
acceptable par la population et non pas
en faisant un pas sanitaires qui se
transforme la moitié de nos concitoyens
aux policiers qui surveillent les autres
sont d'ailleurs avec une fraude massive
et bon sang que ce soit réellement
sérieux nous aurions proposé plus tôt eh
bien d'abord de vaccins le gouvernement
et le parlement et de le montrer et puis
ensuite toutes les personnes en grande
difficulté de communiquer là dessus
quand même en moins mais un olivier
vermont ont offert
survient et puis des soignants et puis
ensuite les forces de l'ordre puis les
pompiers puis les fonctionnaires en
contact avec la population et pas par
paliers pour que ce soit compris et
accepté par la population et pas dans le
chaos tel qu'il est organisé
actuellement donc oui et on voit
effectivement que ça commence à se faire
dans certains dans certains pays
voilà quand est ce que vous disiez par
rapport à l'afrique
est relié à votre question l'un des
problèmes c'est que à tort ou à raison
les citoyens droit de penser ce qu'il
pense et certains ont peur du vaccin est
reine même si c'est à tort c'est
légitime chacun est libre dans ce pays
et bien un gouvernement conséquent
aurait offert la possibilité soit avec
les vaccins fait en france à
saint-herblain loire-atlantique soit en
prenant des en achetant des vaccins
scouts nigré comme pensé le faire madame
merkel soit en achetant des vaccins
souveraineté de sault brénaz dos la caf
avec à cuba qui est efficace à 92% mais
qui sont des vaccins qui fonctionne à
l'ancienne c'est à dire que c'est une
charge virale à l'atténuer c'est pas de
la rn est bien de proposer à ceux qui
craignent la rn d'être vacciné de cette
manière on aurait évidemment beaucoup
moins de problèmes et pour l'afrique est
bien cuba comme à l'époque vu de la
crise de l'ebola va offrir en licence
libre le vaccin souveraineté deux et ça
pose un autre problème qui est lié à
toute cette campagne vaccinale c'est que
on se retrouve à acheter extrêmement
cher et sans aucun contrôle sur le
contenu des contrats puisque c'était
négocier comme le traité de
libre-échange par la commission
européenne à payer très cher des doses
là où on aurait pu
obtenir pour moins cher si ça a été une
crise ayant fait ou si nous avions eu
d'autres options comme les vaccins que
j'ai cités pour en revenir à ce débat
vous avez commencé à montrer d'ailleurs
clairement la question oui pour vous à
la vaccination obligatoire mais fait
différemment jean marc gibeau vous ça
vous choque vous n'êtes pas sur la même
ligne
l'obligation d'une vaccination c'est un
gros mot pour vous aujourd'hui oui c'est
un c'est un gros mot pour des tas de
raisons on peut comprendre ce qui se
passe aux etats unis parce que les états
unis sont un pays qui est en fait qui
est enfermé dans une espèce de judiciary
sme extrême et ça arrive en france
puisque on est tous béat devant ce qui
se passe aux etats unis et c'était
edouard philippe qui l'année dernière
avait bien expliqué dans son livre
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait le risque
judiciaire et qu'ils prenaient tous les
ministres y compris le président de la
république prenez en compte ce risque
judiciaire et donc la vaccination
obligatoire on commence à avoir le
sentiment aussi que c'est peut-être un
peu pour ça mais nous sommes surtout
contre la vaccination obligatoire parce
que c'est le c'est la négation même de
la de la politique vaccinale au départ
faut pas oublier que le vaccin au départ
est développé pour prémunir celui qui le
reçoit de développer des formes graves
de la maladie ça c'est depuis les débuts
de la vaccination et ça a été le cas
dans toute l'histoire de la vaccination
à aucun moment on a imposé à des gens de
se faire vacciner pour protéger les
autres même si c'est inscrit depuis dans
le code de la santé publique et dans le
code du travail il ya ceux de cette
notion de vaccinations altruistes
il n'empêche que même pour l'hépatite b
puisqu'on met toujours cet exemple là
sur le tapis pour les soignants même
pour l'hépatite b au départ il
s'agissait de deux protégés des
soignants de contracter la maladie par
leurs patients et non pas l'inversé donc
voilà et en plus de ça on est
aujourd'hui sur un vaccin qui ne protège
pas totalement de la transmission de la
maladie donc ce à quoi on assiste c'est
quoi vous avez des gens et
particulièrement dans la jeunesse vous
avez des jeunes qui sont doublement
vacciner mais qui commence à faire la
fête qui vont appeler des amis pour
faire la fête qui vont absolument pas
contrôler si le copain a été vaccinée
pas vaccinés s'ils un test pap test etc
et on est en relançant relance la
maladie comme ça donc ça n'a strictement
aucun sens il vaut mieux et d'ailleurs
c'était recherche va les skis la
directrice du sihh d'ici d'atlanta qui
l'a qu'il rappelait au mois de juillet
il vaut mieux rester un peu plus
longtemps avec cette politique de geste
barbare qui l'a malheureusement il faut
l'admettre aujourd'hui le seulement les
derrière c'est vrai que vous n'allez
plus au restaurant vous ne faites plus
de concerts du théâtre cc c'est
compliqué quand même geste valeur
pouvait le restant est justement il ya
d'ailleurs les aider le gouvernement
avait imposé aux restaurateurs tout une
toute une usine à gaz pour se mettre en
conformité et du jour où il signe en
conformité en ayant payé des sommes
incroyables par le faire on leur a
imposé un confinement général et les
fermetures donc des moyens il ya des
moyens très concret pour ça et je suis
désolé mais la vaccination encore une
fois c'est le bénéfice risque c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga de la vaccination en
tout cas gabriella talent n'est pas de
cet avis un forcément le porte-parole du
gouverneur
lui l'a changé d'avis en fonction du
courant on va l'écouter avant de vous
donner la marne cher georges contenaient
trop riche et goûter est vrai la tête de
neuf soignants sur dix se sont fait
vacciner que beaucoup de chemin a été
parcouru au niveau national depuis
l'allocution du président de la
république je le rappelais à l'instant
64% au début du mois de juillet près 90%
aujourd'hui et nous nous attendons
réalité est ce que ce soit un peu plus
parce que certains soignants n'avait pas
déclaré à leurs employeurs qu'ils
avaient été vaccinés c'est aujourd'hui
finalement au moment de vérité entre
guillemets ou un certain nombre d'entre
eux feront connaître leur statut
vaccinal à leur employeur ou et les
satisfait à ne pas parler des
gouvernements toujours danser mais c'est
une entrée leur gabriela talent qui n'a
jamais travaillé commencé très tôt au
ministère de la santé où il était sous
françois hollande quand madame touraine
était ministre de la santé il était avec
monsieur verrons
monsieur salomon où tout le monde était
déjà là toute équipe était déjà là et ce
sont ceux qui sont les principaux
fautifs de la destruction de notre
réaction nationale aux crises sanitaires
alors en dehors du vaccin pas vaccin
nous n'avons pas la même la même
approche mais à république souveraine
nous avions à noter dès fin février 2020
que en observant sans avoir les moyens
d'état qu'a le gouvernement que les
coréens
parce que l'on à un état qui gouvernent
ils ont des gouvernements qui gouverne
dans l'intérêt de leur pays qu'ils ont
une industrie qui peut faire des
respirateurs des masques ont combattu le
virus et sont sans avoir jamais rien
fermé sauf un mois parce qu'ils sont un
petit peu inquiétés ils ont fermé
pendant un mois en deux en un an et demi
des discothèques donc ne rien faire mais
leur économie est en très bon état par
rapport à la nôtre au moins deux
premiers morts pour une population de 50
50 les restrictions quand même assez oui
à une pension de famille oui mais ça
c'est dit c'est ça gouverner c'est
horizons ils ont contraint parce que
parfois il faut compter une liberté d'un
confinement va oui mais nous on a eu un
confinement pour l'ensemble du pays
pendant des mois le il confine qui
confinait les malades pendant deux
semaines et les gens qui étaient autour
d'eux et on voit que ça a fait beaucoup
moins de casse tant psychologique que
que dans l'économie mais donc gabriel
attal a participé à des sélections entre
autres des épreuves donc les
établissements publics de réaction aux
urgences sanitaires toutes ces choses là
qui nous qui nous ont manqué pour réagir
à cette crise donc il est vraiment très
très mal indiqué de s'exprimer sur ce
sujet d'autant plus que le directeur
général de la santé monsieur salomon lui
oui c'est des palmes académiques en plus
il a une responsabilité personnelle dans
le fait qu' il n'est signé pas
suffisamment de vaccins un pardon de
masques dans le pays il a utilisé ses
pouvoirs ont demandé à ses services de
masquer sa responsabilité ce qui a été
repéré par une commission sénatoriale et
il a pas des montagnes il n'a pas été
démissionnée est toujours là monsieur
gabriel talent
on avait bon dos le tout le monde n'est
ce pas la question mais moi je pour
rebondir sur la corée on a l'exemple de
la france métropolitaine en raison de ce
qui s'est passé dans les dom ce qui
s'est passé dans les dom tom est un vrai
scandale là encore il fallait aller au
devant des populations parce qu'on
savait que ces populations étaient un
risque il y avait des facteurs de
comorbidité énorme et puis pardon mais
le par avec la corée du nord la corée la
corée du sud a coïncidé pas une île de
montréal et elle est tellement isolés
que ça n'ait quasiment une les la
guadeloupe la martinique la police des
sondés ils n'ont plus de frontières mais
justement on verra combien plus des
choses qu'ils ont fait encore mieux les
protéger c'est à dire que variant les
variants ils ont été importées sur
saisine on aurait quand même plus là où
il n'y avait pas de diffusion de la
maladie on pouvait en avaient le devoir
de protéger ces populations là et
comment j'ai entendu olivier ferrand
scepticisme tant en outre mer sur la
vaccination geste était un énorme
travail à faire là dessus il y avait la
sphère de chlore qui donne enfin bon il
ya un passif aussi avec l'état français
aux antilles donc il faut redonner
confiance à ces gens là mais moi quand
j'ai entendu je conclurai là dessus
olivier ferrand prendre l'avion pour
aller à la martinique et dire que il
envisageait d'acheminer plus tard des
anticorps monoclonaux moi je suis désolé
mais nicolas dupont aignan président de
la république il prend pas l'avion sans
avoir une cargaison d'anticorps
monoclonaux dans là pour soigner les
gens dans la soute de l'avion merci à
tous les gars du coup on a un petit peu
débordés dépassés au delà de ce débat
sur la vaccination obligatoire mais le
jeu merci en tout cas tous des deux
georges kosmatov beach et et jean marc
flipo merci à vous et c'est la fin de
cette émission dans 30 minutes un
nouveau point sur l'actualité
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve dans cette
grande interview un peu particulière
puisque nous l'avons réalisée en marge
du forum franco russe du développement
durable se tient ici à paris dans les
locaux de la représentation commerciale
de russie avec nous antoine perrut de
bonjour bonjour vous êtes cio comme on
dit dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales quand vous êtes plaît
pas trop quoi de saint gobain russie
ukraine ne l'a pas depuis combien de
temps je suis revenu à deux réunions
alors c'est intéressant que que nous
puissions vous interrogez parce que vous
êtes une entreprise multi lundi à porter
les multinationales parfois cerfa l'on
appelait la google de l'isolation ou ou
de ou de la construction s'était pas
c'est pas rien mais vous aviez déserté
un petit peu la russie